and we can choose whichever flip-flop we
want by the address and then we can
strobe the W thing to write it to that
one or that one but what about reading
how do we combine the two outputs from
our flip-flops into a single output
which we'll call D out here I'm going to
move this paper so will let me just copy
that quickly
so I've redrawn things now without the
input side of things that circuit would
be exactly the same but to make things
easy when we talk about how we get the
output out I've just wiped it away so we
can just refer to what we need so we've
got the two flip-flops zero and one
again we've got our address input and
we've got one output which we called D
out now the first difference from
writing is that we don't need any sort
of read signal to say we want to read
the value because we have the output
always Liv's throwing whatever's in flip
got one or in flip-flop zero what we do
need is to connect the output of
flip-flop zero and the output of
flip-flop wand combined with the address
input to D out so that when there's a
zero on here we get what I was in that
one there and whenever there's a one in
there we get whatever's in that one and
the way we do that again is we use a
NAND gate so we can start off by putting
a NAND gate in here connected to that so
now we have when a in contains zero the
output of here will always be zero when
a in contains one the output of here
will be whatever the value of Q is
that's from the truth table we saw for
the last one and we can do the same just
in the same way for this one here so we
can bring the output down and we can put
it into a NAND gate
and actually a NAND gate is symmetrical
so it doesn't matter which input we
connect things to we can use a not gate
again make that in there and connect
that that so now whenever a in contains
zero this output here this not gate
contains one and we end that with this
thing here so we now have two values if
a is from zero then this one has the
value of Q and this one is guaranteed to
be zero because that's going to be zero
anything ANDed with zero is zero so the
we'll always be zero if it contains 1
this will be 0 because anything ended
with zero from the not gate is 0 and
this will contain whatever this value is
Q it so we now got two signals which are
either the value from the flip-flop if
the right flip probably said that did 0
or want all it's 0 so you need to
combine these two together to produce
our output and the way we do that is by
using an or gate looking at the inputs
like that so what's coming on here well
let's think about the truth table for an
or gate
we have our two inputs a and B and our
output Q so we've got a value of 0 and 0
0 or 0 is 0 0 or 1 is 1 1 or 0 is 1 and
1 or 1 is obviously 1 so what we've got
happening here when 18 is 0 the output
of this and gate is 0 so anything odd
with 0 is whatever the value of the
other one is so B is 0 or 1 so the
output when this is here is whatever the
value of this output is on the other
hand if a in contains 1 this and gate
will contain the value of Q and it goes
in there so it'll either be 0 or 1 but
this one will be 0 because this well we
won inverted 0 and it was 0
everything is always going to be 0 so
we've got 0 on the second input so 0 or
0 is 0 1 or 0 is 1 so again the output
and my follows the other input and so we
can very quickly just using a nor gate
this time merge the outputs of the two
and gates to create D out and actually
we could design the circuit so all of
these things were done using NAND gates
because they're one of the simplest
things to build particularly as we've
got the inverted outputs from a
flip-flop again you could build that out
using many address lines and many all
gates around gates to produce your whole
memory and that's how static Ram like
you'd find out here works you have the
equivalent of a flip-flop for each bit
and you have address pins that decide
which ones are stored
but not quite there's actually another
trick to how the memory is arranged in
your typical RAM circuit to make things
fit onto a piece of silicon easier so
what they actually do is rather than
having and we're going to use four
flip-flops here rather than having them
arranged in one long line like that we
actually arranged them into a grid and
so we now have two rows 0 or 1 and 2
columns 0 or 1 so in this case we'd have
to address inputs a 0 and a 1 and we use
one set of these to select which row it
is and we use the other to select which
column it is so if we want to access
flip-flop 0 then we select row 0 column
0 not access for the foot 1 we select
row 0 column 1 want access flip for
three we select Row 1 column 1 so we
have a grid effectively of cells where
we can store our data and then again we
have the multiplexer is using all gates
to combine them together to produce
output and then we can stack these in 3d
to produce the sort of 8-bit outputs
like I've got here so this is a 626 4
chip which I've pulled out of the BBC
micro made in West Germany that shows
how old it is it's probably made sitting
by this week 15 1986 on here you've got
8 input outputs for the data and a read
white select pin 5 volts input 0 volts
input and the rest of it will be says 8
case is 8 1 9 to memory locations that's
2 to the power of 13 I think and I shall
also do 2 to the power of 12 2 to the
power of 11 2 to the power of 10 so that
Shawn can check it on the calculator and
select the right fitting that I've
written down so we have 2 to the 13 and
if you look at the data sheet for this
memory chip which I should bring up on
the laptop so you can see that we
actually have a row decoder which gets 8
inputs
and a column decoder a zero a nine a 10
11 and a 12 so this 8192 members
locations and they arranged of a grid of
256 rows and 32 columns and of course is
then stacked eight high so they can
store each of the 8 bits it's exactly
like the way of streets and houses
arrange to places like Manhattan you've
got a grid of things and you select
which Street you want and which Avenue
you want and you go to that intersection
and that's where the memory location is
stored only if the two inputs differ if
they're the same then the outcomes are 0
so here we go a 0 exclusive all of the 0
they're the same it's 0